[Music]
what was the straw what were the straws
that broke the camel's back with respect
to
alcohol and seeking help
well there were a couple important
inflection points um
one of which was getting two duis
essentially in a row
with ridiculously high blood alcohol
contents
looking at jail time
my boss finding out at the law firm and
and being on the precipice of getting
fired
that's a whole rabbit hole you know sort
of chaotic disaster that i weathered
another one would was uh
a marriage or i should say like a
wedding that went awry uh
yeah
i got married and that that uh
relationship ended on the honeymoon
which is a whole crazy story story
that is inextricably linked to i mean i
was sober at the time but it's very much
linked to you know my alcoholism
so there's big events like that but i i
think
you know those situations created such a
deep level of shame inside of me that i
wasn't able to
shake alcohol in the wake of those
experiences because i didn't have the
emotional tools to process them so i
continued to drink for a while i mean
the
the wedding was really you know the
nadir of the whole thing and a
reasonable person would have woken up
and gotten sober at that time but i
needed to medicate myself through
that
emotional [ __ ] storm
until one day you know i i basically
woke up and it was i was hungover but it
wasn't like i had
you know i reaped any kind of chaos the
night before but it's just that moment
of realizing like i've had enough like i
can't live this way anymore it's it's
just so lonely and desperate and it only
leads in one direction
and i think you know that's what it
takes like for anybody who has
experience with addiction particularly
substance addiction
you have this sense like you asked me
earlier on tim like when did i know i
had a problem like i knew i had a
problem very early on in my drinking
career but that's very different from
the willingness to do anything about it
like i harbored this notion that this
was a problem for me but you're also
protecting it because you want to be
able to keep doing it and that's what
that's what leads to you know this sort
of double life where you're hiding your
behavior from other people and diluting
yourself into thinking that they don't
know what's going on but ultimately you
realize like everybody knows what's
going on and
on some level
it's a process of like stripping away
those those layers of denial until you
can really
you know face the objective truth of
what you're doing and that's a very
terrifying thing and and so that's kind
of what was going on inside of me
until
you know this day in 1998 where i was
like okay i've had it like i'm i'm ready
to really take this seriously and do
something about it how old were you
roughly then my math is is going to fail
me at this moment but 1998 yeah i was 31
31 all right and
because
it struck me as a curveball if you don't
want to get into it that's totally fine
but
in my mind i envisioned this honeymoon
just going down
as a fireball due to
some catastrophe that was alcohol
induced but you said you were sober
are you willing to expand on that at all
and if not that's fine yeah no
it's so hard to describe this and have
it make sense but essentially what
happened was
i had been drinking quite a bit i got
engaged to this woman
i was living in san francisco at the
time she
was living in palo alto and is from palo
alto
but in the
kind of lead up to this wedding because
we had gotten engaged i had taken a job
in los angeles so we were living in
separate cities and i think during that
interim period when she got distance
between me she realized like maybe this
isn't the guy i want to marry
and i had come clean with her about the
duis and i think that was very scary to
her so
even though i had been sober for a
number of months and and told her that i
was committed to this path of sobriety i
think you know in her heart of hearts
she really wanted to get out of this
relationship but she was unable to
muster the strength to break it off
herself and i think that she wanted me
to break it off and so there was so much
energy behind this impending wedding
that was happening that it just kind of
transpired without anybody hitting the
brakes and i was trying to be
conciliatory and say because i knew she
was off and not present and something
was wrong and i would say are you okay
like what's going on how can i make you
feel
comfortable with all of this and it's a
much longer story i go into detail about
it in my book but
essentially you know she
she permitted the wedding to go through
but then
then didn't want to sign the marriage
certificate
that's a red flag
right
cause for paws yeah and you know the
night of the wedding when we went back
to the honeymoon suite that did not go
well i'm surprised that we even went on
the honeymoon but i think in my mind i
was thinking i'm gonna try to make this
right and it's all gonna work out like
that was its own level of delusion
and while we were on this honeymoon in a
on a caribbean island it was clear that
this relationship had had no future and
ultimately we were able to have a
conversation about it and she ended up
leaving early and at that moment i was
left with myself with no tools and
having been sober for six months
but unable to really process the
the emotional devastation of having you
know just basically had everybody that i
cared about in the world with like 12
groomsmen in this wedding wedding in
palo alto
you know bear witness to
a marriage that clearly wasn't gonna uh
you know work out and it was really
devastating to me so
um i ended up getting drunk on that
island and really struggled to uh get
sober again for quite some time after
that
so thank you for sharing that uh 1998
31
i've had enough
how do you seek help or what do you what
are your next actions after that
so prior to that i had been court
ordered to alcoholics anonymous so i had
been to
meetings
but i wasn't doing it because i wanted
to get sober i was doing it because i
was compelled to do it and i think
that's an important distinction
especially for people who who are
struggling or have people in their lives
that are struggling with a substance
issue
you want to help them you want to
intervene
and you can create you know
interventions and things like that to
get people into treatment but ultimately
if that person is resistant to it or
isn't interested in getting sober that's
going to be a very tough hill to climb
so willingness is like crucial
so when i was attending those aaa
meetings i i lacked that level of
willingness it was more like i just need
to get people off my back so i can go
back to living the way that i want to
live and why is everybody bugging me
but
in the wake of that wedding experience
when my drinking got more and more dire
my parents had reached the level of
their tolerance threshold with me and
basically my dad said listen we love you
um but we just can't continue to watch
you destroy yourself like this and we
can't have anything to do with you
but if you're
ready to get sober we're of course hear
from you but until then um
you know we're we're just we're not
available to you however
because they were so terrified of of all
of this they had found an addiction
medicine um
psychiatrist in los angeles and they
said we have this guy you know it might
be great if you go and see him so i
started seeing this
addiction medicine specialist
and
he knew you know he just rang my bell
immediately and was like here's the deal
dude you're an alcoholic and you need to
go to treatment until you do that like
nothing's going to change and your
life's going to continue to be terrible
and i would try to negotiate with him
and say well i think i can do it in a.a
so i was kind of in and out of a doing
my own self-experimentation with trying
to get sober
but every time i would crawl back into
his office and i was honest with him and
i said yeah i relapsed again or this
happened
but at some point i made a deal with him
because he was like are you ready to go
to treatment i was like let me try one
more time
and he said okay
and to his credit like i think that's a
really
interesting approach like you have to
back off a little bit and allow people
to have their process it's like
inception like they have to
come into this awareness on their own
you cannot compel somebody to
see themselves as as they really are and
of course i relapsed crawled back into
his office and because i was considered
myself such a man of my word i said well
i made a deal with you so okay now i'll
go to i'll go to treatment and that's
you know i called him after this one
bender and i said i'm ready and he got a
bed for me and i immediately go online
and i'm researching treatment centers
and i'm looking for that like the spa
resort one you know that
that's in that has really nice
accommodations he's like no no no
here's where you're going this place in
oregon i got a bed for you like get on
the plane today and that's basically how
it began
you